thank you
thank you
and we are all on the same side
all
oh
uh
is
[Music]
here we go
so here we are
this is a very
satisfying i would say except the clause
so
so so very tragic and sad
the passage of this important
legislation
special name of the imminent will into
the engine
lynching act landmark legislation that
will designate mentioning as a federal
state crime uh we are here listening to
the heroes of this legislation uh comes
bobby raj
a civil rights hero
we know
a strong advocate for this and other
types of legislation
that reject hate in our country but
lynching
but lynching why did it take so long
and then
betty thompson isn't here just yet and i
don't know if he'll be able to join us
but
he's been a champion of course and he
represents
mississippi
it's nearly seven years later
uh they mentioned that eminent tale is
seared into america's collective memory
um
representation
mississippi and how you have been
forcing us on this issue to make sure we
came back
we had no problem with democrats passing
that
majority
before you came in joe madison new york
radio
uh
a great civil rights leader of the john
white he
sort of pulled my chain and said we need
to get this done well that's good
at the
end to meet the reference that joe
madison
has been
promoting this for a long time
and by the way
he and mr
bobby rush have been
confused
what's really
important is that joe has
conveyed to a younger audience
a much younger audience
the
us to do tragedy dependent recognize the
impatience that we have
and now we have succeeded and it's
really the message that i say all the
time our inside movement is really
important but the outside memorization
and messaging of it really makes things
happen so thank you very much
so now i'm going to sign the bill
and bobby
and our special guests
[Applause]
[Music]
and now just imagine as a matter of a
short period of
law of the time
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
legislation but it just still seems
hard to believe that it took this long
to get an entitlement
every time
members of the asian american asian
pacific community who have been
assaulted 11 000 just in the last couple
of years
so there is this
attitude in our country that there's
some license
to hurt people and that it will go
unaccounted for we cannot get that in
the case we cannot believe that people
are asian or whether they were
african-american
so this is how
um
[Music]
there it is
thank you very much
[Music]
h
now
[Music]
[Music]
oh
well done
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
wow
[Music]
oh
um
screenshots
me
bye real
oh
lawyers
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
right
so
okay
field
oh yes
see
we need to speak
down nine
thank you
oh
there he is
i always like you know i don't trust i
it is crazy
so i'm gonna cover here
[Music]
i think i'm gonna exit that
way yeah
i guess
yes
okay
the program to begin with
will you see
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
great
[Applause]
okay
so
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states accompanied by the ceo
and president of the national coalition
against domestic violence ruth glenn
[Applause]
good afternoon
what a time this is right
we've waited
um
and we are thrilled to be here in this
moment
the violence against women act addresses
domestic violence
sexual assault dating violence and
stalking
and this reauthorization does it in a
more holistic way
as a pre-vawa survivor of domestic
violence
i personally understand the importance
and as the ceo of the national coalition
against domestic violence i also
understand the importance
for those of us in this room answering
the calls of survivors
literally and metaphorically we
understand that survivors are not one
dimensional
individual survivors have different
needs and different life circumstances
some live in rural communities
and others live in urban communities
some have children and others do not
some need housing some need advocacy
and some do not some need housing some
some survivors reach out to law
enforcement for helping others reach out
to their communities some survivors are
young persons and others are older
adults
some have disabilities some do not
we believe that vawa allows us to meet
all survivors where they are with
responses and services specific to their
needs
for those of us in this room such as
myself who have survived some form of
violence
we know too well what can happen when
our specific needs are met
ncaadv are colleagues of the national
task force to end sexual and domestic
violence
and every person who has worked for the
past five years for the
reauthorization are glad to be here in
this moment
we in this room also want to thank the
advocates on the ground who have devoted
their lives to working with survivors
of domestic violence and sexual assault
advocates are the backbone of the
nation's response to gender-based
violence and with this bill this nation
has committed to them as well
these five years of hard work to renew
and strengthen volvo would not be
possible without the same tenacity and
compassion
of all including bipartisan members of
congress and their staff
and including a man who became champion
on these issues more than three dead
three decades ago
a person who solve a need
listen to survivors
walked with advocates
and challenged others to join him and
those survivors and advocates to improve
our nation's
laws and help change the social norms
a man who led the effort in the senate
to write the first law and to keep
strengthening it over the years
a person i had the privilege of
introducing in 2014
during our collective celebration
of the 20th anniversary of law here i am
again
he has set the standard for ensuring
that the voices of survivors and
advocates are heard
and that we continue expanding
opportunities for safety prevention
healing and justice
i am honored and pleased to introduce
the person who took up that charge and
is now our nation's leader president joe
biden
thank you
[Applause]
first of all
as i was standing there listening i
should say that
thank all of you everyone in this movie
it didn't change the law we set out to
remember some of you way back when i
first wrote this legislation
to change the culture
[Applause]
she was a serious victim of violence
left uh for dead basically
before this law was written
you make me think of
the women who are willing to come and
testify before the whole
world i first started those hearings
it wasn't viewed even among the advocacy
groups it's necessarily a particularly
positive thing to do
it was uh because anyway you know
thank you for your courage for being a
hero sharing your powerful voice
and standing up for thousands of women
and that could be said about most of you
in this room
i want to thank the members of the
senate house members of my cabinet
for all you've done the idea that this
took five years to reauthorize
i was out of office those years
[Applause]
it's wonderful to see so many great
survivors and dedicated advocates and
truly old friends
so many have worked so hard to modernize
the violence against women act make it
stronger make sure that it endures
and the reason we've been able to
do
so much make so much progress the past
20 years is because of all of you
i know some of you aren't even 28 years
old so the type of council
are all kidding aside it really does
again i keep coming back to change the
culture not just the law
i want to thank the bipartisan members
of congress who helped
get this latest
[Applause]
lee
i learned a long time ago
just say yes it saves time
jerry matt is a great friend and a great
congressman and brian fitzpatrick brian
thank you
thank you for coming together and never
giving up you know the fact is it really
wasn't so long ago in this country
didn't want to talk about violence
against women
let alone as being a national epidemic
something that government had to address
as a society we literally looked away
we looked away
many places it wasn't a crime
and i don't recall i recall how many
times i was told in a prelude to writing
legislation it's a family affair you
don't understand by it it's a family
affair
when i began along with others through
this legislation that changes this issue
we were told that we would literally
be responsible for the disintegration of
american families and major press it
wasn't just the wackos
it was in the mainstream press
and we talked about creating shelters
give survivors the way out because some
of them are way out and their children
by the way the vast majority of children
on the street the mothers are there
because she's a victim of domestic
violence
and here's what they said here's what
they wrote he said
these shelters providing shelters
was nothing more than indoctrination
incentives for women's liberation issues
now i can get to the car
not a joke
not a joke
and calling the police
meant having to stand in front of your
abuser
your significant other your husband
whomever
and say he did it
and i used to say when i get heat on
this when i spoke i remember making a
speech at chamber of commerce and
someone said you're going overboard here
i said let me ask you jack
i said you had a 320 pound guy who can
bench 400 pounds stand in front of you
and beat that smack you you're going to
say he did it
because you know he's going to come back
look
a few there were very few police
departments
that had trained personnel
i mean very few i i'm sure there were
some i just can't remember any of them
no i really mean as a matter of fact i i
don't think there were any special
victims units in most of the police
departments around the country before
this legislation was written
now there's programs that
are on tv and for the last 25 30 years
no but i really mean it it mattered
that's what i mean about changing the
culture
look
there were too few places you could go
for advice for help
where would you go and how many times i
remember the biggest fights i had
seconds around universities
with universities
where do you show up
reporters
i mean major universities
not not dunk university major
universities
it took time to change the culture and
you did it
i did it
there was no national hotline
i remember going all kidding aside
there have been millions of women who
hit that hotline
i you know all the brave guys i've
talked to they because they fired you
over doing this
and i'd say tell me tell you what
if somebody who was twice your size
beating the living crap out of it you're
in the same apartment with them
how do you go and pick up the phone and
call for help
women would hide and say i can't i can't
say right
now i don't know
help me help me
that's how we got microsoft and others
in this in this fight with us
to help us physically locate so the
police could pick up where that call was
coming from
that was a background when i first wrote
the lines against women act in 1990
to provide more protection against
domestic violence stalking sexual
assault to support survivors and help
them find ways out of their abusive
situations
and say why didn't why didn't she leave
well she didn't think she had no place
to go and she had two kids with her
no money
nothing
no family to go to
leave
i'm gonna ask
time to time
was there is a reason i guess i got a
little overwrought about this
legislation early on
not that i ever get overwrought
but and i i i literally the most off
asked questions for the first three
years of the act
was
well why are you so passionate about
this what was your mother a victim of
domestic violence
was your sister
or your wife were they
were they victims swear to god that was
the most off asked question of me
i said no that's not the answer i happen
to be raised
by a gentle decent man
who taught all his children i mean this
was out of my heart basically you know
this
you knew my dad
my dad would say the greatest sin of all
that anyone could commit was the abuse
of power
and the cardinal sin
for a man to raise his hand to a woman
or a child
that's what this law has always been
about
the abuse
power
whether it ends in a rape or just a
physical base about the abuse of power
so
i believe that many of you in this room
did that i believe that too
and the only way we could change the
culture was by shining an ugly bright
light on it
and speaking its name
make all the speeches you wanted
but until those women had the courage
and i remember remembering in the back
room
holding us it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay
can you imagine being among the first to
stand before the whole damn world
and millions of people
here you recite how you were abused
it took enormous courage
at the time
majority leader might remember we both
got criticized for wanting to make it
public
we don't want to do that
we don't want to do that
that's why we help public hearings for
this law
when there were senators and others who
said it was too salacious
for this to be public
for people to see
you know we but i believe that a lot of
us did that we had to let america know
what was going on take the blinders off
make them look at it square in the eye
all the ugly side of it
because i believed as all of you did the
americans were basically decent
honorable people
but they didn't want to get involved
didn't want to get involved
how many times have you been in a
crowded airport or
in a circumstance where you see a man
not physically meeting but abusing a
woman
well i believe that if they could see
the truth of what was going on
you could begin slowly to make change
that's exactly what you all did that's
what happened
this law broke the dam of congressional
resistance and cultural resistance
it brought this hidden epidemic out of
the shadows
you know it's an introduction i've
introduced our nation and so many brave
survivors those stories changed the way
america saw the issue i mean in a
literal sense
it's hard to believe i even when i go
back and think about how it started
where it was
as a practical matter things began to
shift
illegal and social burdens
away from survivors and on the
perpetrators
and where they belonged
made addressing general excuse me gender
violence a shared priority
with a determined coordinated response
i created the hotline as i said for
millions of women
who have used the hotline
and again i'll never forget being told
the first time
i said what did you do said i got behind
the drapes
don't let them hear this praying god
praying god
supported shelters and rape crisis
centers
housing legal assistance
life-saving options for women and
children all across the country
to help train police officers advocates
prosecutors judges court personnel
to make the entire justice system fair
more responsive to the needs of
survivors
i'll never forget
chris i went to the family court when i
was readiness
and the family court of my stakes like
many of yours
and i watched because i was told this
would happen
i watched the woman
come up to the desk and say
i want to report
that
my husband's beating you
why don't you have a seat over there
not a joke
go back and check your family courts
back in the day
that's what happened
that's okay you you over here
we'll get to that no no i
can you
you know the laws save lives
it's helped women rebuild their lives
the hardest thing to get done was arrest
on information
because what used to happen is
a cop may be in the street and see
a husband or a boyfriend or a man anyone
smack his wife
they come over and say do you want to
bring charges
what does she gonna say
yeah i want to bring it we got the lady
lord jesus to say the cop can arrest on
information he saw it happening
all these bad
tough guys
even in 1994 we knew there was much more
we had to do
you know that was only the beginning
that's why because of all of you in this
room every time we authorize this law
it's been improved
it's not like we didn't know we wanted
to do these other things in the
beginning
because we did as much as we could and
keep trying to add to it you remember
you sent me a test a lot of times
broadening from domestic violence
includes stalking
sexual assault in 2000. that was the
change man
expanding access to services for
immigrants and communities of color in
2005. that was a challenge
restoring jurisdiction of tribal courts
[Applause]
[Music]
we did that in 2013.
extending protections to everyone
regardless of sexual orientation and
gender identity
[Applause]
all of you i really mean it thank you
the law kept growing stronger it's not
like we didn't know in 2005 we should be
dealing with the things we dealt with
was getting it done
each link in the chain
that we're building made a difference
makes a difference
yesterday
i signed the bipartisan government
funding bill thank you very much that
the consequence before the next link in
the change
not only not only did we reauthorize
bonds consumer act through 2027 i have a
wonder why the hell we can't reauthorize
it like the voting rights act i thought
we had won when i got strong thurman to
vote for it and extended for 25 years
and then the court came along but anyway
that's another issue
you know i don't just think about this
if this affected
manhood the man
i don't think we had problem
you know doing it for even longer making
it permanent
look
we deliver more help to survivors of the
ruler
we understand in an underserved
community
for simple reason
there's no place to go
well whether it's arizona or whether
it's michigan wherever it is
you're in a rural area you call you get
help and you do get help and then they
leave in the next years
next year's town is 20 miles
how long does it take for the cop to get
there
tribal courts will now be able to
exercise jurisdiction over non-native
perpetrators of sexual assault child
abuse
you've all added
new services and resources for folks
most underserved communities the lgbtq
community survivors of both rural
communities providing more support legal
services for law enforcement to get
training they need to help handle the
trauma of survivors that are
experiencing
and by the way it's not a criticism of
the police
we for all the mistakes police make and
all the things they do wrong
we expect to be everything from a
counselor to a expert on sexual violence
to a expert on all these things but you
know these are vast majority people with
you know degrees that are two-year
degrees after school i mean they're
smart but i mean we accept to be
psychologists we expect them to be
everything
so we established a new civil rights a
new civil rights cause of action
for those whose intimate images were
shared on the public screen
how many times have you heard i bet
everybody knows somebody somewhere along
the line that in an intimate
relationship
what happened was the guy takes a
revealing picture
of his naked friend or whatever in a
compromising position
and then literally in a sense blackmails
or mortifies that person
send it out put it online
give your survivors real resources
against abuse
ex-partners and stalkers who seek to
humiliate and hurt them
we've created you've created new
programs help end the backlog of the
rape kits
those rape kits by the way
i don't know you ought to go to your
major cities those of you in the house
and senate this group probably has
which i have done
and this backlog is so significant
you could solve literally a significant
portion of look the only thing i learned
that's worse than for a woman
worse than a woman who is
is abused or raped
and
says it's charlie who did it and no one
believes for him against her
and
when you can take a look if you take a
look at those rape kits went through
them all you could identify and arrest
probably
40 50 of the rapists in america
they're all there
their dnas are there it's all in line
and running against the whole pen
very few rapists rape only once
so look
that you know there's a lot that goes
unprocessed
and we have to make sure survivors get
compensation and if there have been
delays in their cases
now we made improvements in the national
criminal background check system to help
states investigate and prosecute cases
when abuses
when abusers who are barred from
purchasing firearms attempt to do so
that we've done federally
quite frankly this held that's one of
the things that held up this bill for
much too long
much too long
those are just a few of the ways we
strengthen you you not really you've
strengthened the law because i just came
under back on the range again
but look it comes on top of the work
we've done together over the last years
to make progress we know the pandemic
only exacerbated instances of domestic
violence and sexual violence it shot up
like a roman candle
and through the american rescue plan the
administration directed one billion
dollars in supplemental funding for
domestic violence and sexual assault
services
[Applause]
local public housing authorities to make
sure that survivors trapped in a bad
situation could find safe new housing
options in public housing
we also made landmark reforms in
military justice to help end the
epidemic of sexual violence and
harassment
prosecutes sexual assault domestic
violence other related crimes
thank you
kristen gillibrand
thank you
[Applause]
earlier this month i signed a bipartisan
bill that ends what we know as forced
arbitration
that's wonderful isn't it
in a small print set you can't do
anything
if your boss
male or female
if you end up getting abused
if you end up doing something
you can't you have to do it internally
no more
[Applause]
mecca has prevented too many survivors
of abuse and harassment in the workplace
from having a choice to get their day in
court look they're just a few of the
steps you've all taken and how much
you've improved this legislation
but as everyone in this room knows this
work is not going to stop it never stops
today one year since a gunman killed
eight people in atlanta six of whom were
women of asian descent
these horrific murders are a reminder
that we still have work to do to put an
end to misogyny and racism and all forms
of hate we have we're never going to get
it all done we can't ever stop trying
as long as there are women in this
country and around the world who live in
fear of violence there's more we have to
do to fulfill this sacred commitment
no one
no one
regardless of gender sexual orientation
should experience abuse period
and if they do they should have the
service and support they need to get
through it
and we're not going to rest but in the
meantime all of you should be enormously
proud of what you've accomplished
this reauthorization is testament to the
power of your voices and your tireless
dedication to changing things for the
better
and one last thing
some of you in here helped me work on
the international violence against women
and
[Applause]
a very short concluding story when i was
vice president i can't remember practice
seventh year in on thereabouts i was in
india
and i met at the home
where uh
mahatma gandhi was
able to be hidden
for a long while
and uh
and and i met with the two of the
daughters of india's most
serious
liberators
and you know i thought they're going to
ask me questions about you know us
indeed relationships said
can you help us write a violence against
women
not a joke
just by some of you speaking out
republicans and democrats just by you
speaking out
about
how we abhor
those nations that do in fact call
forward through the list
is changing behaviors
i think we have to even be stronger than
that but that's another
that's another boring speech
lord
let's keep going
thank you all may god bless you all and
may god protect our troops thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
exactly
oh
you get a picture
yes
congratulations
thank you
[Music]
like what it means
okay
it's ginger
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys
how are you
thank you
thank you
this
oh
oh
[Music]
how are you
hi
how are you doing
oh
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
is
is
okay
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
great
[Applause]
guys
[Music]
she's
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exactly
this is
okay
oh
oh
everywhere
wow
five
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
wow
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
nice
i don't know
okay